[APPLAUSE]
[MUSIC - AVERY SUNSHINE,
"I GOT SUNSHINE"]
[APPLAUSE]
AVERY SUNSHINE: Y'all
are so sweet to me.
I'm so glad I didn't
wear my shoes.
Y'all make me feel good.
Do you know this is what
I absolutely love to do?
So you all make me
feel like they're
going to have to turn
the lights out on us
tonight because I'm
going to keep on singing.
I love you, Ryan.
Ryan told me to keep singing
until the exit signs go off.
[MUSIC - AVERY
SUNSHINE, "PININ"]
AVERY SUNSHINE: Y'all
are so wonderful to me.
I swear I could do
this all night long.
Can we do this thing?
Any house heads in here?
Man, we're gonna pick it up.
So listen, Craig
is in the house.
Craig, would you wave
your hand real quick?
So one of the first songs
my partner and I, Dana,
wrote was a song
called "Stalk You."
So I'm just going to
sing a little bit of it.
I want you all to hear it.
And I actually travelled
to Japan with Craig.
Do you remember that?
In the name of Jesus.
So this is the song.
Listen.
[MUSIC - AVERY
SUNSHINE, "STALK YOU"]
AVERY SUNSHINE: I just had
to give you a little bit.
I love you.
Baby, can we do
"Sunday Morning?"
I just want to do
a little thing.
My honey asked me to do this.
Yo, I move so fast through these
I'm gonna have some coffee.
I'm trying to get it.
Ryan, how much
time I got, honey?
I'm jamming on to one.
Thank you.
So listen, this is one
of my favorite songs.
And I decided we were gonna
do something different.
So I hope you like this.
Listen.
[MUSIC - AVERY SUNSHINE,
"SUNDAY MORNING"]
AVERY SUNSHINE: Y'all like that?
Yeah, I love that song.
So I wanted-- there were a
couple of songs from the new
record I was gonna let
y'all hear tonight.
So I was gonna do
one real quick.
What'd you say?
Huh?
But no, if I do
two of those, then
I can't do the other
songs that they--
you know what I'm saying?
Very well?
Did you hear Ike Turner?
Did you hear him?
So I've got to set
this up really quickly.
So I have to say--
something that we never
really talk about.
We never talk about
equal love and all that.
And I was blessed to be born
into a family where my eldest
brother is a same-gender
loving person.
Y'all know what I'm
talking about, right?
Absolutely.
And I felt like I wanted to
address that because he's
the godfather of my children.
And I wanted people to know that
one of the best examples that I
have seen for love had been
with my brother and his partner
of some 20 years.
So I figured out
the way I could say
this was something like this--
[MUSIC - AVERY SUNSHINE,
"SEE YOU WHEN I GET THERE"]
AVERY SUNSHINE: Thank
you all so much.
And that means so much to me.
I hope you all like that song.
My brother hasn't heard it yet.
I can't wait for him to hear it.
What you say?
I've got to go now?
Oh, very well.
I've got to do this real quick.
I can do two?
Well, I've got to serve
the Lord real quick.
[MUSIC - AVERY SUNSHINE,
"SAFE IN HIS ARMS"]
AVERY SUNSHINE: Oh,
Jesus, I'm sorry.
I'm going to pass
the plate right now.
They're telling
me I've got to go?
I can't do another Ugly?
I can't do any of that?
Who?
[INAUDIBLE]?
All right, see, we're
just all over the place.
This is the most special show
you've ever been to, huh?
I'd like to do that song.
And I'm just gonna
say thank you, God.
Because the reason
I was on the radio
was because a program
director in Chicago
said that God told him to
put my song on the radio.
That doesn't happen,
y'all, to independent.
It just does not happen.
So I'm grateful.
I'm so grateful.
So I'm a sing a
little bit of this.
I'm a try.
[MUSIC - AVERY SUNSHINE,
"UGLY PART OF ME"]
AVERY SUNSHINE: Y'all all right?
Did you all have a
good time with me?
Next [INAUDIBLE] other artists.
I love you all.
That was what you
call a power set.
But put your hands
together if you can, y'all.
I want to do a little bit.
Here we go.
[MUSIC - AVERY SUNSHINE,
"ALL IN MY HEAD"]
[APPLAUSE]
RYAN LOREN: Welcome
Avery Sunshine to Google.
It's so good to
have you here today.
AVERY SUNSHINE: I'm
so glad to be here.
RYAN LOREN: Yes.
AVERY SUNSHINE: I'm sorry.
I'm so out of order.
I'm so excited.
Well, you know that.
You know why I'm excited.
RYAN LOREN: I'm excited, too.
AVERY SUNSHINE: This is huge.
RYAN LOREN: Yeah.
This is going to
be a great night.
AVERY SUNSHINE: Yes, it is.
RYAN LOREN: So I just wanted
to have a little chat with you
before we get started.
So Avery Sunshine--
this is your name.
Can you tell us about your name?
AVERY SUNSHINE: Well, my
name is-- it's so funny.
My partner-- I don't know why
he's not in here right now--
Dana, wherever he is.
Dana and I, we
worked on-- I never
thought I was
gonna be an artist.
I didn't think I
sang well enough
or I was talented
enough to be an artist.
And Dana was like, no
listen, listen, listen.
I think you've got something.
Let's just start writing
and see what happens.
So the first song we wrote-- and
we're going to sing it tonight.
The song was called "Stalker."
And I know, I know, I know.
But I wrote the hook.
And I said, Dana, I'm
gonna send you this hook.
I can't get you out of my
mind and all this stuff.
Just good stuff.
And then, I'm not the kind
of girl who'd stalk you.
But I might call you over
and over and over again.
So we wrote the song.
And a good friend of
his was a house DJ.
And he wanted to remix it.
And he did, and it was amazing.
And he said, OK, we're
about to put the record out.
Who do you want to be?
I was like, what does that mean?
He was like, well, you
can change your name.
I was like, well, what's
wrong with Denise White?
And they were
like, well, there's
nothing wrong with Denise White.
But if you want to-- you
could do something else
if you wanted to.
And I blurted out
Avery Sunshine.
And I believe--
and it's so funny
when I tell you I never thought
about being an artist before.
I hadn't.
At least, I didn't think I had.
But I think it comes from
my love of two characters.
The first character is Shug
Avery from "The Color Purple."
And then the other character is
Sunshine from "Harlem Nights."
You throw it up in the air
and it turns to sunshine.
It's all adults in here, right?
There's no children here.
But if you don't know
what we're talking about,
please rent "Harlem Nights."
You'll know what
I'm talking about.
In no way-- whatever the case.
But that's how I got the
name, just blurted it out.
RYAN LOREN: Well, it suits you.
AVERY SUNSHINE:
Thank you, honey.
RYAN LOREN: Yeah.
I think you have an energy
that's contagious ever
since I met you.
AVERY SUNSHINE: It's coffee.
RYAN LOREN: Is it coffee?
I was going to ask.
I know you've got kids.
I know you're always upbeat.
Is it coffee?
AVERY SUNSHINE: It's coffee.
Because otherwise-- you
know, you have to be.
With kids and keeping
up with what's going on.
With a career as an independent
artist, you'd better be.
RYAN LOREN: So for those of
you haven't heard your music,
how would you introduce
people to your music?
What's your style?
AVERY SUNSHINE: My
style is R and B soul.
And there's a thread,
that common thread
of gospel through it all.
But I'm still talking about my
baby daddy and life and stuff.
But I hope that it
makes people feel good.
So I like to call it
feel-good music, to.
RYAN LOREN: Great.
AVERY SUNSHINE: So I hope it
does make people feel good.
RYAN LOREN: I think it does.
And I was a little
surprised to hear
you say you weren't
planning to be an artist
or weren't expecting that.
But weren't you involved in
music at a pretty young age?
AVERY SUNSHINE: Yeah, I was.
Now I started playing
piano at eight.
And I started directing
choirs and playing
for choirs at the age of 13.
So I was reading music.
And I had an aunt.
Her name was Aunt Tootsie.
And Aunt Tootsie called my mom
one day, said, listen, Ruth.
Listen, I'm working at
the Catholic church.
And I can't be
there this Sunday.
I've got to go to Tahiti.
Can Denise come read this
order of service real quick?
And my mom asked me, Denise,
do you want to try it?
And before I knew how much
money it paid, I said sure.
The service was one hour.
And I had been $175.
Just to go in and
read some music.
I was like, I'm through.
That's my career.
That's it.
But I felt like I was
always behind the scenes.
I was directing the choir
or accompanying someone
but never-- you know, and I
would sing out of necessity
if somebody didn't
show up to do a solo.
That's how I would
end up singing.
But never, you know what?
I'm going to sing a solo today.
I just didn't
think I-- you know,
some people like that
If you go to church
you know that one person.
Yeah, I'm just gonna sing
the "Star Spangled Banner"
for the Lord today.
We didn't ask you to do that.
I was not that person.
I tell you, I am such a fan
of that real, real singer,
the Clark Sisters
and Stevie Wonder.
And I was like,
if you don't sing
like that-- that's
what I thought.
And you've got a thing, too,
because everybody that can sing
doesn't have a thing.
And I didn't think
I had that thing.
I didn't know.
And when I tell you
this was so divine,
I feel like it just fell on me.
And then Dana and I
met, and it was really--
Dana, wave your hand
so everybody can see.
That's my partner, everybody.
[APPLAUSE]
Yeah.
Yeah, without him there
would be no Avery Sunshine.
So feel free to
call him Ike Turner,
Rick James, Joe Jackson.
RYAN LOREN: Great.
Well thank you.
So tell me more about the last
album and what it meant to you.
And then-- we'll do
that first and then
we'll go to the next question.
AVERY SUNSHINE: The last
album, which was my first,
it marked a point in my life.
I was going through a divorce.
I always say this.
And I didn't go to therapy.
I probably should have.
But the record served
as therapy for me.
I was able to talk about
what I was dealing with.
And I'ma tell you--
if you don't know,
stuff is better on the outside.
I just believe it.
And I was able to get it out
and make it to the other side.
So that record marks
that time in my life.
And I'm grateful for it.
I look back on it like, wow.
I'm glad people
liked it because I
was going through some of that.
One of the songs, I was crying.
Dana was like, I
don't know if we
need to put this on the record.
I was like, no, but, ooh, I
just want people to feel me.
RYAN LOREN: So then what can
we expect for the next one?
AVERY SUNSHINE: More crying.
No, I'm not gonna
do more crying.
A different place.
You know, this next
record is going
to be entitled "The Sun Room."
And if you have a
house, the sun room
is that place where
you go put up your feet
and do whatever it is
you feel like doing.
If you feel like talking
on the phone, you do that.
You want to watch a little TV?
You do that.
If you want to look out and look
at the lake, you can do that.
Whatever it is you want to
do, that's your sanctuary.
And I want to encourage
everybody to find that place.
So this next record is
called "The Sun Room."
And whatever has been on my mind
as well as Dana's-- our minds
this last year so, that's what
we're talking about again.
But it's definitely happy.
RYAN LOREN: Good.
The last one, it's
just interesting to me.
I've always thought
it was fascinating
how music is therapeutic.
You said you didn't
go to therapy.
But it sounds like
you sort of did.
AVERY SUNSHINE:
Thanks to all of you.
If you have the record, you
helped me with my therapy.
Thank you.
RYAN LOREN: I'm looking
forward to the next one.
So before we go, just a
couple of favorites of yours.
What's one of your favorite
places to see live music?
AVERY SUNSHINE: Oh, one of
my favorite places to see--
RYAN LOREN: In any city.
AVERY SUNSHINE: In any
city to see live music.
I have to tell you-- London.
Ronnie Scott's.
It is really, really tight.
If you haven't been, please make
a trip to London and check out
Ronnie Scott's.
It's half the size of
this room right here.
And the intimacy, it's electric.
I fell in love with
music again in that spot.
And I hope to play
there one day.
RYAN LOREN: I'm going
to check it out now.
AVERY SUNSHINE: Please do.
Please do.
RYAN LOREN: What's one of your
passions outside of music?
AVERY SUNSHINE:
Directing choirs.
That's-- outside of music.
No, my children.
My children.
We, my son and I,
are movie buffs.
So we have dates.
We try to have
dates once a week,
he and I. And the last date
we had, as a matter of fact,
my daughter was
supposed to come.
And he was feeling some
kind of way about it.
And he was like,
can you drop her off
to get her hair done so we
can really have our date?
But I'm taking it seriously.
I want him to-- my dad and I
used to have dates like that.
I want my son to learn how
to treat a woman, or anybody,
by me spending that time
with him and showing him--
not just telling him.
But we do it.
We do it.
And the last one we
saw was Superman.
What's the name of
it? "Man of Steel."
I was a nervous.
It was a little dark.
who did Clark Kent first?
What was his name?
Michael Reeve?
Christopher Reeve.
I'm sold out for
This new stuff-- that's when you
know you're getting older, too.
Like, see this newfangled stuff.
RYAN LOREN: So how
old are your kids?
AVERY SUNSHINE: My son is
11 and my daughter is 13.
And my daughter,
she wrote a song
that's going to be on--
she and Musiq Soulchild.
Yes.
It's going to be an
interlude on the record.
RYAN LOREN: That's incredible.
AVERY SUNSHINE: It's nuts.
And I played it.
Well actually, she
played it for me.
And we listened to
the track on my phone.
And we recreated it for her.
And when she heard it, she
was like, that's not right.
So y'all need to do it again.
RYAN LOREN: That's incredible.
AVERY SUNSHINE: So I'm
excited about that.
RYAN LOREN: Cool.
Last thing-- what was the
first CD you remember buying?
AVERY SUNSHINE: The first CD--
I don't remember buying one.
But I remember-- I
tell you, it's strange.
I remember CDs came out.
And I remember
waking up one day,
and there were three
CDs at the house.
There was the Yellowjackets
and my parents
had the Clark Sisters.
And then there was one
more-- Kenny G. It was.
What's the one?
The wedding song?
The sound quality from a tape
to CD made your head pop off.
Am I the only one
that remembers that?
To hear that?
Oh, what is it?
It just felt like water.
You just feel like it's
life to hear that sound.
It was amazing to me.
I remember those distinctly.
I don't remember buying them.
Just one day they
were at the house.
RYAN LOREN: They have
a way of showing up.
AVERY SUNSHINE:
They just showed up.
But I remember those two
three CDs distinctly.
And the sound was just amazing.
RYAN LOREN: Great.
Well, there's a fourth one
I'm looking very forward to.
It is yours.
So thank you for joining us.
AVERY SUNSHINE: Thank
you so much, Ryan.
It'd mean so much to me.
Ya'll, I got to-- please
make some noise for Ryan.
Because for all the artists
that are here tonight,
it means so much for us to
be able to share what we do
and the way we want to do it.
And we just don't have
the platform all the time.
And I'm speaking for everybody.
We are grateful.
And we're grateful
that you're here
to listen and share with us.
And we thank you because
you didn't have to.
You could have said,
let me call Beyonce.
RYAN LOREN: I do sound like her.
And I have her
number, of course.
But yeah, I didn't.
AVERY SUNSHINE:
But you could have.
You could call anybody.
And you chose us.
And I'm grateful.
And we thank you so much.
RYAN LOREN: And likewise.
And there's a reason
I choose you guys.
[APPLAUSE]